this is the first question okay now if
you went properly through and did the
whole gasoline relation thing and then
substituted correctly to get the
identity matrix then your brows ought to
be very similar or identical to what
I've got
okay I'll show you what here's where you
started okay now you can see this line
here that's where I first got row
echelon form okay so you can see the
zeros are here in the corner the
quickest way to do that is just like I
did in the previous example try and get
zeros in the front and that means you've
got two variables two constants to
pronumerals left right and then do what
you need to to this one to make it a
zero as well and then BAM you're there
okay so in this case what did I do
I think from road to I subtracted what I
subtract I needed 10 2 into a 0 so I use
this guy right - lots of our 1 right Row
3 is even easier to turn this into 0 all
I have to do is add Row 1 ok from here
to here if I really want to get it in
reform like so without swapping rows
even though you can do that that
negative turn that 4 you've got to
multiply by both right so it looks like
I multiplied this 1 by 4 and this 1 by 3
right and then once you've got these two
you can add them together and that gives
you row echelon form okay from there all
you need to do is a bit of dividing
divided by 8 subtract divide by 12
negative 12 and then I just subtract all
of the original rows and there's my
answer if I had given you a system you
know anyone could be negative 3 B would
be 2 and C would be 3 okay here's my
question multiplying by 0
we looked at 0 and division by zero and
why that was a problem last time but in
matrices even multiplication by zero is
a problem okay has anyone worked out why
it's really easy to see if you just have
a look at this final endpoint okay now
we're done we've finished we've got our
solutions for this okay but just
consider what would happen if I multiply
the word
ami road by zero okay watch if I take
say the last run let's multiply that by
zero your first two rows are unchanged
and your last row what would it become
or zero zero zero zero zero you'll like
no problem right like if I wrote that as
an equation it would mean zero into a
and zero and lots of B and zero lots of
C that equals zero isn't that true it is
true so there's no problem with this
line right it's not saying anything
false aha I've well now here's
interesting
I'm kinda nervous it seems natural say
I've lost C but what you've really done
is you gained every seen C can be
anything there are no more constraints
on C right you can put C equals 5 or 2
million or negative 1 or anything you
like in there any real value and it'll
work so where's the problem where's the
lie it's that you see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
systems they're all the same the
solutions for this system the same as
the solutions for this one and this one
and for the rest but this system is not
the same it's got extra solutions right
so nonzero trivial as it might seem
actually is really important